[Music]
we recently saw the addition of Robin to
injustice tues roster and now we've
gotten a look at what the Caped
Crusader's trusty sidekick will be
capable of in-game I'm Matt and holy
gamespot news update Batman Bruce
Wayne's son Damian dons Robins red green
and yellow and injustice to in the
official gameplay trailer we see that he
makes liberal use of a sword which you
can probably guess doesn't make Batman
too happy special batarangs also seem to
allow him to juggle enemies and teleport
you can check out the full gameplay
trailer over on gamespot's as for other
characters at Boone said the roster will
be the largest at nether Rome fighting
game has seen so far and will include
more obscure characters from the DC
Universe he also confirmed that
third-party characters will come as dlc
for injustice too thanks to the
popularity of Jason Voorhees leather
face and the xenomorph in moral Kombat X
injustice two launches for ps4 and xbox
one on May sixteenth for more news about
the fighting game and the world of video
games stay tuned to gamespot